[Music]
hug it every night and sleep at the end
stop cinema with this Sunday the kids
get to take over Dancing with the Stars
in the first-ever juniors edition but
says this is flashback Friday what we
asked the grown-up mentors to remember
when they first hit the ballroom young
Cheryl she danced and only loved to
dance that's the only thing I never
complained about when I was a kid all
those early days on the dance floor paid
off for Cheryl Burke after winning to
Miraval she's mentoring Stevie Wonder's
15-year old man Lou Morris I was on the
show when I was a little older than them
back in 2008 during season 6 of Dancing
with the Stars the show featured a
juniors competition and crowned 13 year
old Brandon Armstrong the champ now 10
years later he's coaching Disney star
Ariana Greenblatt before Sunday's debut
performance I won the mirror ball so I'm
trying to get these two to get the same
cries and long before glitz if chinko
was mentoring Dance Moms star Mackenzie
Ziegler and posting shirtless southeast
well he was a 14 year old burning up a
Russian ballrooms I remember when I was
like aid I just used I just love hanging
out the competitions I didn't want to
compete even at a young age I would love
I would like to perform for my family at
night like just I didn't want to go to
sleep
skateboarding star Skye Browns mentor
Allen person's passion for dance started
in Minnesota dance halls when he was
just seven years old and believe it or
not I was one of the attention pros Emma
Slater and Sasha Farber were just
married last March and both grew up with
an identical love of the ballroom check
out this home video of a little Sasha
with a severe case of dance fever in
that video I was five years old
and I still do the same moves quite
embarrassing and how adorable is tiny
Emma marching to the beat of her own
drum entertaining her dad and twin
sister Kelly with her very own dance
shows in the bedroom of her UK home well
we are gonna be there for Sunday's debut
episode so tune in Monday for that
[Music]
[Applause]